- [Interviewer] Amanda.
Amanda, Where are you
from? Where'd you grow up?
- [Amanda] Inglewood, California.
I was born in Centinela hospital.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
So you're an LA girl.
- [Amanda] Yup, LA.
- [Interviewer] And you
grew up with both parents?
- No, I didn't have a mom growing up,
it was just me and my father.
- [Interviewer] Where was mom?
- I don't know, on drugs somewhere.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
And how was life at home with dad?
- It was good.
I had to move to my mom's family's house
so I grew up with them.
They were my grandparents,
it was cool growing up with them.
- [Interviewer] So you left
your dad at some point?
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- I felt real lonely with
my dad, so they took me in.
We didn't really go out to amusement parks
and stuff like that so
they just took me in,
because cos they had the money.
I just went with them, it
was just a better situation.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Any problems with dad?
- No
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I have a little issue.
- I think that he's
doing stuff to my food.
I think that he's spitting in my food.
That's an issue that we have right now.
I moved back with him when
I was like 20, 22, 23.
I don't know what he's doing to my food,
but we got to talk about it
and hash it out for sure.
- [Interviewer] And life with
your grandparents was good?
- Yeah, It was real good.
I didn't feel lonely anymore.
They bought me clothes,
shoes, anything I wanted.
- [Interviewer] That's nice.
And what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I was a tomboy.
- [Interviewer] A tomboy?
- Yup
- [Interviewer] Do you
have brothers and sisters?
- Yeah, I have one autistic brother.
He has autism, so I had to help
take care of him growing up.
It was cool.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- 24.
- [Interviewer] You're 24.
Did you finish high school?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You did?
And where'd you go when you left home?
- I went to CSUN, Cal State Northridge.
- [Interviewer] For college?
- Mhmm.
- [Interviewer] Oh how many
years did you do in college?
- Two.
- [Interviewer] Two years-
- Then I dropped out, I
wasn't really doing any work,
just smoking weed so I dropped out.
- [Interviewer] Wow, and then
what'd you do after that?
- I moved in with my boyfriend.
- [Amanda] It was a tricky situation.
I did some things that I regret,
it wasn't really a good situation.
So we broke up and I moved
out here on Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] What stuff
with your boyfriend was?
Well, I kind of showed him pictures
of a girl named (indistinct)
to get his dick hard,
So it wasn't good.
It failed our relationship completely.
- [Interviewer] Where you
doing any drugs at that point?
- Yeah. I was doing weed every day.
- [Interviewer] Skid Row
is weed and a lot more-
- Yeah, I do crack now.
- [Interviewer] You do crack?
And how long have you been down here?
- A couple years.
- [Interviewer] You're on the street?
- Yeah. I stay with my
dad in a one bedroom.
He sleeps on the floor,
I sleep in the bed.
- You're in a room.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're not in
the street, you're in hotel?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
- It's like a studio apartment.
- [Interviewer] What do
you do for money now?
- I prostitute
- [Interviewer] You do?
- Yep. I have to.
- [Interviewer] Does dad know about that?
- Yeah. he doesn't say, but
I know he's proud of me.
Because I can't do anything else.
- [Interviewer] You can't?
- I can't, I've tried.
I tried working at PetSmart, bonds,
It just doesn't work out.
I always make mistakes.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you been working
as a prostitute?
- A year now?
- [Interviewer] Do you like it?
- Yeah, it's okay.
- [Interviewer] It supports
all your bills and drug habits?
- Yeah, mhmm.
Pretty girl like you
probably has (indistinct).
- Yup.
- [Interviewer] What do
you charge for a date?
- Like 20 to $30, sometimes
it depends on who you are.
If you're real cute, I'll
suck you off for five or 10.
I do that all the time.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
oral sex or intercourse or-
- Everything, I do everything.
I just started having sex on the blade,
I call it the blade.
- [Interviewer] And where-
- Before I just gave head.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
And where do you go to
do this? A car or do you-
- We go to alleys.
It's real scary because I feel
like I'm dodging a murder-
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you are.
- so it gets scary.
Sometimes I have to stop jobs
in the middle of our session,
just to stay safe.
- [Interviewer] And your crack
habit costs you how much?
Roughly a week?
- A week?
Probably like $500 a week,
I've spended on crack.
Crack is the most expensive drug-
- [Interviewer] Oh I'm
sorry, you doing meth, right?
- I do crack.
- [Interviewer] Oh crack, I'm sorry.
So crack's a-
- Crack is an expensive
drug to keep up, for real.
I feel like it's one
of the best drugs ever.
I've done every drug,
I've done crystal, weed, speed.
I've done every drug.
- [Interviewer] Have you tried heroine?
- Heroine? No, I've never done heroine.
I need to try it.
- [Interviewer] You need
to? I'm not sure you do.
- After I get off crack.
- [Interviewer] You might
not be able to (indistinct).
- But recently the sun
unorthodoxed herself to me.
Basically, she's giving me a ultimatum.
I gotta get off crack or
I'm gonna get murdered.
Because I'm getting extra good
horny from the government.
So they patrol what I do.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry, say that again.
I get extra good horny.
So if you come in session
with me and prostitute
and help my business, you get extra horny.
You get more hornier than you
would with another prostitute.
- [Interviewer] Really?
Yeah. So they govern what I do-
- [Interviewer] Who's they?
- The government and the sun.
- [Interviewer] And the sun?
Yeah, the sun, God.
- [Interviewer] Let me
just get this straight,
The sun and the government
will make me extra horny
if I have sex with you?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What
are you doing tonight?
I'm just joking.
(Amanda laughs)
That's interesting, I've
never heard that before.
- Yeah, so she wants me to get off crack
because it's too much.
- [Interviewer] Who's she?
- The sun and the government.
- [Interviewer] Okay. I'll
have to think about that.
- Yup.
- [Interviewer] Thank you
so much for talking to me.
- All right, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting talk,
and do you have any plans for your future?
- Just to continue prostituting,
so come check me out, I'm on Skid Row.
(Amanda laughs)
- [Interviewer] All right.
- All right.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Be careful out there.